Jack Prescott wearing his mississippi
state colors i got his jacket there
haven't come over there Paul got
slip-ons
look at you look at that Jack Prescott
in the house here looking clean quite a
grip just on it you just stepped off a
yacht here I think is what it looks like
there yeah Jack Prescott here looking
clean got missed no that's not by an
accident you got Mississippi State color
jacket on right yeah represent right now
College World Series I like that - oh no
did you play baseball I did not did you
play basketball I did were you any good
I was pretty yeah I was pretty good a
solid what's that mean what I mean much
we didn't have that great of a
basketball program in my high school so
at six - I was playing the four so ooh I
mean I did some work all district you
know what you averaged 18 okay wait you
said that little too quickly there well
I know if I'd have made more free-throws
I probably got 25 so I did you want to
play college basketball no I mean I knew
exactly what I wanted to do always
wanted to play football so at what age
did you say to your mom I want to be an
NFL quarterback probably as soon as I
could talk really I've always always
wanted to play playing in a field
quarterback mommy says to eat sleep and
breathe football so nothing's changed
but did you always play quarterback no I
didn't I started off playing linebacker
and running back and then once I once
the coach's son move to a different what
happened if the coach's son didn't move
to a different position
well the coach's son didn't play in
middle school so maybe it would've
happened at that would you have made the
NFL at a different position
I don't know always wonder that maybe
like a utility player the tight end the
F that F position I think I could you
got good hands yeah I mean yeah they
would be better if I was well plus you
get to wear those gloves that's true
those gloves aren't fair deck they help
that's performance-enhancing right I
mean it helps me so I'm saying
but have you ever had a guy complain
that you threw too hard to him on high
school never really uh in the NFL or
nobody cuz they want you to throw it to
him they don't care how hard they just
want the ball so yeah they're not
they're not griping about how hard it
was or something like that maybe if
you're warming up though you know Sen
trying to tell you to take it down a
little bit but growing up in Louisiana
Saints fan know always a Cowboys fan
always a Cowboys fan when I was when I
was a kid saying I wanted to play
quarterback in the NFL was saying I want
to play for the Cowboys but okay so
favorite player growing up was who with
the Cowboys Emmitt Smith okay
okay did you meet Emmett yeah I've met
him it I mean I've met all the all the
cowboy legends all the greats and yeah
him it's a close friend but you asked
for autograph or no you don't know what
you want you're exchanging numbers and
and talking and stuff like that you
can't ask for an exchange in jerseys and
uh you can't do that
no I wouldn't do that it's kind of weird
like hey can I get one of yours and I'll
give you one of mine you got to make
sure that they want you this is the key
this is the trick it's where you have a
buddy who said hey why don't you two get
together let's get a picture here yeah
that's the right yeah I've got the
buddies to help me out just to get the
picture that's the move there yeah that
works
and then Troy you met Troy do you meet
Roger Staubach yeah Roger he's probably
my favorite nothing against sent me now
but just Roger non Roger and everything
he's done on the football field serving
our country the businessman oh yeah he's
the he's the greatest and I you
obviously weren't alive to see him but
what he did when he did it how he did it
was something that nobody was playing to
position that way he could he would play
now with the you know run-pass option
like Roger was just he was a great
athlete once he had to wait what six
years to get into the NFL so I think he
came in 228 yeah he was well ahead of
his time yeah he was he was playing a
game you're joining us on behalf well
tell us what your you're talking about
today yeah the ready raised rise
campaign as you said partnered up with
my second team bristol-myers Squibb yep
it's the picture right there and that
picture goes right in right in right in
hand with our challenge
with the ready razor eyes campaign is
about is bringing awareness and research
education I was excuse me education to
the immune oncology research which
focuses on how each cancer is unique and
individual and how your immune system
can help you fight off the cancer so our
challenge all right there's you get that
picture
pick your power going to ready raise
rise calm a poster photo showing us how
unique and powerful you are with a
picture and once you do that 100
submissions bristol-myers Squibb has
promised to donate a quarter of a
million dollars so we're not asking for
your money we're just asking for you to
go to the website submit a photo and
help help raise this awareness so we can
defeat this nasty disease you could stay
for a little while we're gonna take a
break here and then we'll come back with
dak Prescott talk some football the
hashtag ready raw ready race rise so Dax
got football there and McLovin puts on
an eagle dad this is you said yeah fine
we didn't have a Cowboys I'm gonna find
the team that he's had the most success
connecting with I looked at his game I
thought we were playing nice McLovin I
also have known Ole Miss helmet in the
back yes Fritzi and he's saying we
couldn't find a cowboy son but I'm
pretty sure right above dak Prescott
head right there's a cowboy helmet right
there's a cowboy helmet
McLovin okay first of all I'm just
kidding around of course but if I put on
the Cowboys helmet if I catch wasn't the
Jerry Jones gonna be the first place
okay are you gonna take the jacket off
to throw I need to yeah okay do we have
the video
pauley of when Rogers was at the Super
Bowl and he threw two McLovin yeah we
have a montage montage okay so I just
want to let dak Prescott know that this
is the great company that nearly killed
McLovin so if we get that opportunity
here's some of the video here so Alex
Smith gonna bring it okay all right and
Alex you know McLovin made fun of his
his arm that's a lie
drew brees drew brees if
knuckleball at him through the
watermelon Thanks Case Keenum lit him up
dan Marino and Aaron Rodgers now watch
the second one here's the second one
oh so there Aaron Rodgers was trying to
hurt ya you're gonna have to you have to
take the jacket off there yeah whose arm
do you want out of that group now you
can't have yours but if I said you could
have somebody else's arm oh great
question yeah and Rodgers I guess I'm is
that here's the natural just arm just
the whip to it but I mean I'm a big drew
brees fan yeah then but Drew's Drew's
delivering everything he's a lot of
mechanics I mean from from his feet to
his shoulders all the way through the
delivery but just straight whip getting
the ball out there Rodgers right okay
but when do you realize what you need to
do to be an NFL quarterback throwing it
because you know you can be successful
in college but right there's that point
where the scouts are gonna look at it
differently and say okay can he get the
ball off does he have you know that
quick motion or whatever you need but
when were you told that this is what you
needed to do to be an NFL quarterback I
mean I had a lot of doubt I mean a lot
of people never said I could be the NFL
quarterback but for the most part it's
it's about knowing what's best for you
what works for you I think it starts off
mentally in your preparation you have to
know where you're going with the ball
before you have a chance of getting it
out at night I mean some people have
have enough form strength to be late and
still get the ball there in time so I
mean for me it's about being on time
with with my reads and then just being
able to get at they're just there's
natural finding what's best for me
give me a play in college at Mississippi
State and then give me a play with the
Cowboys yeah I mean a play in college so
we're not all about formations yeah
you never hold it up first off okay all
right so I just like signal you some
stuff so it'd be out our free I mean I
really forgot the formation but like
they gonna say Rock so it'd be two hands
or Rocking hope they don't still have
this in Mississippi State giving things
away
or because modeling in Florida who knows
but then our protections were we're
numbers like Barack 65 Houston skinny
which are two different car here's ten
concept remain concept in the skinny
with the okay receiver and then the
Cowboys
yeah the Cowboys I mean we have some
plays that they get deep I mean
obviously with our fastball with they're
on the ball we can say one play or we
need to say one name when code word and
it spits out the whole play or if you
want a tough one I mean you can B's mo
to gun bunch right out Java right 949
B's drive while return weight this is
one play as one play it can be simple
diet can be there's got to be so
complicated I was just and then the
difference in college I mean kinda I
think it's the game I mean the NFL's
evolved into that but the NFL tells
everybody pretty much what to do within
that play like each numbers for each
particular receiver depending on when I
said it and the new tagged bees bees
return bees mo like motion him somewhere
returned him we're in college is just
like you better know where you are ever
got some line of scrimmage and forgot to
play No thank God
ever made a mistake at the line of
scrimmage yes what did you what happened
I mean probably not making the right
check or sometimes we have two plays and
you ever tell your hand under the guard
no I've never never done them I don't
think so but I went one time I was about
to I was doing all that now lift us out
yeah dropped if you tried to play it off
a little bit late like I was telling the
guard some dinner
when told the other guard something and
then then found my way to the center
could you imagine what the guard would
have done if you put your hands under
there you would have turned around they
lying what's your name
it would have been different it would
have thought I'd cuff to me once I got
in there I know you you have to say all
the right things but you know you lose
weight and lose dez bryant why if I'm a
Cowboy fan
do I look at the Cowboys wide receiving
corps and say there's nothing to worry
about here yeah I mean we have we have
players we have veteran players that we
brought in that you go watch Allen Hurns
you go watch Tavon Austin Deonte
Thompson those veterans that we brought
in there along with Cole Beasley guys
that have already made a name for
themselves that are hard to guard in the
NFL and then we have some young guys
that are they don't come up I mean you
don't make the moves that we made
without knowing you've got some special
receivers for special place how did you
find out Dez Bryant wasn't gonna be
brought back yeah I mean I was working
out and throwing the day of the news and
another receiver I'd came in and told me
and I mean obviously knowing there was
talking on that was not necessarily
potential but that it could happen it
was it was odd I mean me and Dez are
good friends and still continue to talk
here in there so I was odd and music
great player what was more surprising
Whitten retiring or Dez not coming back
I'd probably say the the whitin retiring
I mean just simple fact as we said we
knew but we knew there was a meeting
with Dez we knew something I guess was
going to happen or something was there
to occur but with with wit was just out
of nowhere I mean I think I was doing an
event for the draft and somebody comes
up to me and tells me my boy what what
do you mean he's apparently we just
worked out yesterday but then not too
long after that she had a conversation
with wit and it all made sense
have you been to Jerry Jones his house
no I have it
wait what why I think that you get that
year three have you have you heard what
what Jerry's house is like I mean yeah
it's one of those dudes that I'm sure I
mean I'm sure it's huge but the way
people explain it it's like yeah it's
like a pounce like Jerry Jones it's like
the star it's like AT&T Stadium it's
what you would expect probably to see
have a TV the same size as the jumbotron
in the stadium that's them that's one of
the stories they tell it's a myth can
you go out to dinner and downs yeah I
can how do you do that with it because
you know cowboy fans are legendary yeah
but I mean being a professional a lot of
them I mean they respect they respect my
time and they respect mine my nights out
are my dinner so uh but if you go to
Applebee's no not a chance
I want to love this yeah okay I have to
have to go to the the better places that
help me out not that better than
Applebee's but the places that help me
out and will set somebody you know said
somebody that we have a great town hurt
naked Sam's have some great some great
steak houses next great yeah absolutely
what did you think a cold Beasley rap
album I liked it I mean I like I like
Kobe's a lot of like it was you tell me
if you didn't like it I mean yeah I mean
I'm honest I wouldn't I would okay so I
like it I mean there's songs obviously I
like more than others and did he name
did he name check you at all yeah he did
we did he said he's a dog when Dad gets
the ball out so you put it on you I love
it you know he gave me some credit
what was your welcome to the NFL moment
good or bad yeah I mean I like to tell
the story just doing Pat and go I mean
everybody knows it's it's one of those
almost scripted just to look good but
it's it's a lot that goes into it though
I want you what you play and from the
fan perspective it just the other
tossing the ball there making the
one-handed catches and things like that
but we do it every day at practice and
where I practice and I guess I'm just
kind of you know slinging the ball just
throwing it trying to look good and I
throw it probably a yard out in front of
Jason Witten where if he took one extra
step that he wanted to and if he wanted
to go catch it he could have he could
have caught it but it was a moment for
him to show me what the NFL was like and
he kept running and almost glued his
elbows to his chest and or to his hip
and just let the ball fall in front of
them then looked at me
through the heads up like what the hell
are you doing so that was the moment
then where yeah you've got to be that on
point in the NFL what about your hit
they hit that was welcome to the NFL not
really sure on that one I know playing
the bingos my rookie year I got in this
position in 4-minute wearing 4-minute
trying to run timeout and I was running
toward the sideline so I know I can't go
out of bounds but if I slide I'm a kick
zika's equals I think trying to shut off
vantes Burfict there and a guy got a
little too close to Zeke and then he
kind of slipped and I don't know gave me
a little head button and so it wasn't
necessarily that hard of a hit but it
was the moment I say yeah you better get
down they're gonna they're gonna hurt
you in this leak dak Prescott joining us
tell people what you told him last hour
about what you're talking about today
yeah they're ready Ray's rise campaign
I'm here just on behalf of them in my
team bristol-myers Squibb with the with
the challenge right there with our
challenge to everyone out there we need
a hundred submissions so go to ready
raise raise calm go to the pick your
photo link and show us how unique and
how powerful you are with the photo all
right I have your draft profile all the
greats have done this before him
negative draft profile drew brees did
Drew Brees actually kept it yeah I want
it but he said can I have this because
he wanted this because he wanted his
motivation
so imagine Drew Brees he throw for
70,000 yards he's 500 touchdowns and he
wanted motivation so these are accurate
these are what bit this is what was said
about you going into the draft so Jack
okay we have not edited these these are
the negatives they're a lot of positives
but we intend a negative okay here we go
accuracy on intermediate and deep throws
not short not in capital amortization
ouch
yep hyper aware of pressure around him
and lacks awareness to slide and find
temporary shelter to make throw true
footwork is a mess okay
needs improvement on anticipation must
be more willing to challenge the defense
too often tries to muscle throws with
upper body okay
hmm I've got big legs I think I use my
legs
okay all right tape shows a player who
must improve his mechanics poise and
quickness through his progression
comparison Brett Hundley ouch
now paulie's got just a piece of paper
yes paulie's got the names of those
writers who saw those yeah it rhymes
with Bell Mel Antonio okay yes McLovin
I just want to be clear I did not write
any of that I do not
well I'm Mike like you did when you put
that okay here we go when you ready to
leave
can you walk downstairs McLovin will put
his helmet on so before you get the car
yeah I want you to just bring some noise
towards McLovin you got it all right got
to do that
I'll give us the hash tag and any other
information again yeah go to ready raise
rise calm our challenge is pick your
power and go up and upload your photo
with a hundred submissions bristol-myers
Squibb has promised to donate a quarter
of a million dollars so I think that's
doable I think that's doable by the time
I go down there I make it downstairs and
make this throw so uh I love it yep do
it it's great to see you and you look
great so you know whenever you want to
do to McLovin I have no problem I can
always replace here all right all right
so dak Prescott are the Dallas Cowboys
will come back in fact if you guys want
to start to make your way downstairs
I'll read this deck I'll see you down
there you have your gloves on I
could there really caracals all here we
are down in the in Tribeca
McLovin with his Cowboys helmet on dak
took off the jacket so here we go we're
ready yeah pumped up here from here we
go one more one more one more
ok I really try to catch Iowa see if you
can make his heart stop make his heart
stop yeah see if you can hit him oh come
on all right we got to get a picture
here yes
that's great
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]